Go
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
they're everywhere
they're watching me now
soon enough these days will end
there will be no rules going forward
people are standing up
that's what a reckoning sounds like
Hello there everyone this is going to be my brand
new star wars and or trailer video they finally
released some footage for the actual series
that'll tell us what's going on with the plot
there's a bunch of easter eggs here i'll explain
what's going on with the episodes when they're
going to premiere and what they've said about
the mandalorian season 3 and some of the other
big series that they were showing off footage from
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes of course i'll be doing
full episode videos for this one at premieres
also be doing all the episode videos for obi-wan
kenobi which is pretty much starting right now
wars hello
but the really big news first and or is going
to be premiering august 31st and it's going to
be 12 episodes long it's the longest star
wars series that we've ever had so far
they're gonna show the first two episodes on day
one like a lot of previous disney plus series
but it's still the longest series that we've
ever seen so far it's gonna start five years
before rogue one they already confirmed season two
season two will be the same length but they said
the season two will cover most of the four years
lead up to the rogue one movie and like the very
final scene of the series they've already planned
out will lead up into the opening moments of rogue
one it sounds like it might only run two seasons
i suppose it could run three seasons i think
originally they planned for five but then they
just kind of wintered it down and just expanded
the episode order i think people like longer
series just in general just give us more give
us more a lot of you saw familiar faces during
this pretty much all the same actors that are at
least alive at this part of the timeline the big
characters will show up from the rogue one movie
but as the name implies cassian andor is the
main character of the series even though it's an
ensemble there are several main characters like
mon mothma is featured heavily in the footage
stellen skarsgard's character is featured heavily
during the trailer you have this council of what
looks like either admirals or captains meeting
which is very evocative of a new hope with the
council of moths even though they're much lower
in rank so just in general the series is meant
to give us a more accurate picture in what really
happened during the rise of the rebellion because
they kind of did a speed run version of that
during rogue one like the rebellion already exists
when rogue one picks up it's just in its earlier
days this is really meant to show you the deep
dive into how the rebellion came together and
there are a lot of moments during the trailer that
give you vibes from rogue one like it wasn't all
just the rebellion like there are some imperial
characters that seem like they help sabotage the
empire from within besides galen erso like a lot
of former imperial characters who helped the
rebellion in their efforts to fight the empire
most of the trailer seems like it takes place on
this one very particular planet where they have
this empire processing facility they're building
a lot of things maybe weapons maybe droids maybe
just random parts mostly actual imperial shipyards
like the really important stuff the imperial navy
shipyards were in outer space because the ships
were so large but i love the way they opened the
trailer with this really quiet vibe you have this
worker coming up and just banging this drum as
he's trying to get people to start working also
heralding the empire showing up to start banging
on their doors if you turn the closed captions on
for the trailer it's calling this character the
time grappler i think the idea is that he's just
helping keep general time for the city like hey
it's morning everybody needs to go to work there's
this really cool guttural throat singing as the
empire shows up to start banging on people's
doors and you see townspeople all over the planet
crouching down like something really bad is about
to happen like they want to show you what life is
like under imperial rule the fact that most of
this planet seems to hate it in showing you why
the rebellion actually comes together in the first
place just common people really really hating the
empire and wanting to get rid of them it seems
like from this giant junkyard with all these parts
here and this droid just driving through them
that they're using it for a general parts facility
like they bring a bunch of junk here and use it
in this processing facility in the background
you see a bunch of the workers it's hard to tell
what it is that they're building it seems like
some specialized parts you see a bunch of common
towns people running around trying to hide their
weapons all people who are part of the early
rebellion trying to fight against the empire
but they haven't all come together like they're
all these disparate groups of people it sounds
like at the beginning of the series they're not
actually calling themselves the rebellion yet
just a bunch of pockets of resistance that are
slowly coming together in an organized way which
really happens i think when mon mothma comes
on board with a lot of the other top members
this younger character they're calling solomon
pock imperial troops land start walking through
the city this is all meant to be reminiscent of
those scenes that you saw during the rogue one
movie on jedha the jedi temple with just imperial
troops the empire in general just rolling through
the city wrecking everything that they come across
we see a bunch of cool new imperial uniforms on
these people coming to visit this person question
them the empire is built of billions and billions
of people so it makes sense that they would try to
show you as many different parts of the empire as
possible through all these different live-action
series we finally see diego luna's cassian andor
figure for the first time he talks about this
imperial council of officers meeting in this room
them being so proud of themselves it sounds
like they'll be one of the main antagonists
of the series the main person here in the white
imperial uniform might seem familiar just having
four blue bars on a white uniform meant that they
were a security officer or a stormtrooper captain
much lower in actual rank than a real admiral so
he might not be a full admiral during this series
or this might not be a council of admirals but
like i said it's meant to be evocative of things
you saw during rogue one orson krennic wore a
white uniform he was slightly higher in rank than
these people also a lot of people wearing white
uniforms were part of the imperial security bureau
meaning basically they were part of the empire
secret service big connection to the mandalorian
too moff gideon's character actually rose up
through the ranks of the imperial security bureau
so during this part of the timeline he would have
been marching around in a white uniform as well
we see more traditional lower ranking imperial
officers in more traditional looking uniforms
it seems like most of these scenes of the empire
though are featured in and around this particular
planet like they're managing this imperial
processing facility where you see all the
workers all the townspeople being forced to
labor for them then they show a shot of mod
mothma much earlier in the timeline like i said
five years before rogue one it sounds like she
hasn't become the leader or one of the leaders of
the rebellion yet i believe bail organa is also
supposed to show up during this series as well
too because he also shows up during rogue one the
way she talks about how the empire the imperial
security bureau has been watching her i need to
be careful this could be happening on coruscant
itself because she was an imperial senator
you see another imperial character with a couple
death troopers remember death troopers we saw
during rogue one if it wasn't clear it's the same
actress who played mon mothma during rogue one she
also played mon mothma as a much younger person
during the prequel movies it's just that she's
aged so well that she looks very close to what she
looked like during the prequels it's kind of like
ewan mcgregor with the whole idea of him turning
into the alec guinness version of obi-wan kenobi
like not a ton of time goes by before the original
trilogy picks up and he's supposed to look like
really old man obi-wan kenobi like those must have
been a hard 10 15 years that he lived there on
tatooine we get a forest shot of a couple other
rebellion characters forming together in a much
more sparsely populated area and it looks like
they're calling stellen skarsgard's character
luthen and he actually might wind up being a big
rebellion figure because the uniform that he's
wearing isn't traditional empire even though they
are wearing a couple different types of imperial
uniforms during the trailer we thought that he'd
actually be playing one of the main antagonists
but the big twist could be that he's actually one
of the people who's really important in helping
the rebellion form this seems like a wider shot
of the imperial processing facility where they're
doing a lot of the specialized labor or some
specialized facility that's underwater then
they show this younger imperial character who's
a main character his name is kyle soller but they
don't list his character's name on imdb but he
seems like he's going to be another pov character
but from the empire side of things he seems like
he's preoccupied or obsessed with cassian andor's
character he's giving some galen erso kind
of vibes like he might be one of the people
inside the empire who helps sabotage the empire
helping the rebellion form they're calling fiona
shaw's character who seems like she's part of
the early rebellion marva but when she starts
her voice over talking about the people rising
up rebellion forming like things finally turning
in their direction this is what a resistance is
meant to look like they show a couple shots inside
the senate chamber on coruscant so it does seem
like mod mothma is going to be located on actual
coruscant during the series and they show a bunch
of different locations while they're talking about
people quote-unquote standing up the rebellion
actually forming quick shot of cassie and andor
stealing a tie fighter in one of their facilities
because so much of this seems like it takes place
on coruscant as well a lot of you asking is
there going to be emperor palpatine cameo scenes
will there be darth vader cameo scenes because he
probably had one of the greatest scenes in all of
star wars during rogue one in that ending scene my
guess is that they'll reference the emperor during
the series but i'm not expecting to see a ton of
emperor cameos in the same thing with darth vader
like maybe a little bit of darth vader because
hayden christensen did say the obi-wan kenobi
episodes aren't the only thing he came back for so
like he'll probably do something during the ahsoka
series to do ahsoka and darth vader or ahsoka and
anakin skywalker scenes and there's probably at
least a little something going on with darth vader
during the andor series even though most of it
seems like it takes place between the senate stuff
with mon mothma and a lot of what's happening on
this other planet with cassian andor's character
but my full obi-wan kenobi episode one in episode
two videos will post on friday just like normal
be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that and we might get a mandalorian
season three teaser trailer this weekend if we do
of course i'll do a video for it they also made a
bunch of other announcements about premiere dates
during star wars celebration 2 mandalorian season
3 is going to start in early february right after
the willow series winds up ending that's going to
spill over into january which is why mandalorian
season 3 isn't starting till early february
they also confirmed that the ahsoka series
will premiere during 2023 but we already kind of
knew that that's not a big surprise while you wait
for everything everyone click here for my obi-wan
kenobi episode 1 and episode 2 video i'll update
the link as soon as i post that and click here for
my brand new thor love and thunder trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!